Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Sherlock episode one
video Benedict Cumberbatch.
Doctor strange is back.
So just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet.
There is a Sherlock giveaway that I'm going
to do for each of the episodes I'm going to
give away a copy of the DVD for any season
that you guys want.
So all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a Sherlock related comment on this
video be sure to click that bell, so you don't
miss anything.
So everything seems like it's lost Sherlock
and Watson are at odds it seems like there's
this rift between them there is ever going
to be healed.
We have the grim specter of death in the form
of Moriarty in the poem that they keep repeating
through the episode things that you can't
outrun death is inevitable even though as
a child Sherlock tried to write in a different
way the person went to a different city and
trach death.
So that's the idea of this new series will
Sherlock be able to change the story so to
speak and defeat Moriarty of final time.
Even after his death because I don't think
that they're trying to assert that he still
alive Sherlock's convinced that he's dead,
but that he's left him a game post humorously
like there is one final game they will be
the greatest game that Moriarty set in motion,
knowing that he was getting ready to died
back in season two so that sort of like the
overarching storyline they really only touch
on it at the beginning of the episode and
then again at the end of the episode like
every once in a while you're reminded about
it through the poem but mostly this is a story
about the six factors which is a reference
to the classic home story the adventure of
the six Napoleons so there are like busts
of Napoleon the keep getting smashed six bus
and all the people they get murdered along
the way were the names that they use in the
episode so they almost did that exact same
storyline, but obviously the TV show weave
that in with Mary's back story that was a
change from the classic home story and in
the original story.
They were looking for a thumb drive.
Obviously your talk about like 1900s.
They were looking for the black pearl that
was hidden in one of the Napoleon busts.
So in this episode.
Sherlock thinks that that is what Ajay is
after he thinks that he is after the black
pearl and that's what he's going around to
all these places trying to smashed all the
bus and killing the people, so the important
thing about that is just to remember that
they did not solve the case of the black pearl
it's still out there that might end up weaving
in with the larger Moriarty plot later on
there always times in Sherlock episodes where
you think that the different cases all weave
together.
Sometimes they seem like they're not connected,
but that over the course of the three episodes
they make more sense.
Even though within each episode.
They might not necessarily be as connected
as you think.
So what about Toby Jones the person that we
saw in all the trailers we didn't see him
anywhere in this episode he's really like
the new big bad of season four in the way
that Magnuson was the villain of season three
and that Moriarty was the big villain before
that, though technically Moriarty is always
going to be the biggest villain even when
he's dead, so we'll see how Toby Jones characters
connected to that but we don't know who he's
playing yet they haven't revealed that will
probably meet him in the second episode and
then in the third episode.
Just as is tradition with the series you get
your final big mystery to connect all of the
episodes your technically each of the episodes
is kind of stand alone, with like a loose
plot like this Moriarty plot to get strung
out over the three and it really doesn't come
together till the third episode, so that whatever
the plot is with Toby Jones that will have
something to do with Moriarty's final game
as Sherlock believes that there was a 90 minute
episode so it was packed full of Easter eggs
from all across the Sherlock Canon from the
TV movies from the classic home stories.
So I've already explained.
The six statures Easter egg the black pearl
Easter egg, but when Sherlock says that he's
just going to wait for Moriarty's game to
present itself to him like I was gonna start
solving cases just like a normally would.
So during that montage.
They flashed all that text of all the cases
up on the screen.
Those are all Easter eggs for different home
stories.
So the dusty death case is a reference to
Sherlock Holmes and the jeweler of Florence
the dusty death, is aligned inside the book
but the book itself is quoting Macbeth in
the line is all our yesterdays have lighted
fools the way to dusty death so that in and
of itself sort of loops back around to the
idea that you can't outrun your past their
consequences.
Mary's death was a consequence of the way
she lived.
She wasn't able to out run death it's inevitable's
were like inception third level deep Easter
eggs here thumb with a bag of ice and it is
a reference to a short story called the adventure
of the engineers thumb.
In fact, most of these of the cases that are
mentioned are probably from those Sherlock
Holmes short stories of the duplicate man
I think is a reference to the adventure of
the dancing men which is one of the short
stories.
The circus tour.
So I think is a reference to the adventure
of the veil the Lodger which is another short
story the Canary trainer is actually a short
story by Nicolas Meyer which is that action.
More recently, so that wasn't written by Conan
Doyle, but the jellyfish case like where they
joke about trying to arrest a jellyfish is
a reference to the adventure of the lion's
mane, which is another one of the short stories
in which someone gets murdered and it turns
out the culprit is a lion's mane jellyfish
in the elaborate case that he details when
he's talking to the man whose wife has left
him on the little bit like Sherlock Holmes
and the voice of terror which is actually
like a 1942 film based on the story his last
bow, which itself was used as inspiration
for the title of Series III's finale is the
last bow which is also important in this episode
two, so if you forgot the valve that was actually
Series III episode to his last bow was to
protect Mary the baby and Watson like their
Trinity like the holy Trinity with his life.
So in his grief.
Watson now blames Holmes for breaking his
vow allowing Mary to die.
So, as is the case in the past.
Sometimes though, have like a big time jump
between episodes so like episode two might
not pick up in the moments at the end of this
episode like we might be a couple months down
the road so of course we think that Watson
Holmes will mend the rip somehow Sherlock
will find a way to uphold the terms of his
vow to Mary in a promise me that you will
save Jon Watson but in doing so like we've
seen in the trailer like you see Watson down
here in the well silence of the lambs style
it puts the lotion on his skin is just going
to test the limits of what Sherlock is capable
of, and it all comes back around to what Mycroft
was telling them about how sentiment is such
a bad thing, how it's gonna get him in trouble
down the line he definitely came off like
a real villain when he was trying to ask him
about Agro like what is this thumb drive was
your involvement with them.
Did you use this assassins group for a little
while during that scene.
I actually thought that Mycroft was going
to be the one to have betray them until we
learned that it was actually the receptionist
who is just upset about the life that she
chose not to lead.
So the whole metaphor here is that Watson
is like slowly, turning into this old lady.
So Sherlock has to save him from his grief,
so that he can come back out and live a full
normal life.
But as is the case with most Sherlock episodes
is packed with Easter eggs.
It was amazing you can definitely tell they
took their time building this script to just
like so packed with stuff you can watch is
a couple times and find even more Easter eggs
that he was the dog.
The dog was great is kind of a metaphor for
red beard which is sort of the change in Sherlock's
emotional armor just proving that is not a
psychopath.
He is a human, with human emotions red beard
was his dog as a child they flashback to it.
Whatever he got knocked out by Mary in the
episode, so presumably something really bad
happened of the dog and it died and he just
tore him apart.
Every time he remembers it.
Now he just goes a little bit nuts, but speaking
of chinks in the armor.
So Mary's death very emotional now Sherlock
is in therapy, just like Watson was in therapy
at the beginning of the series way back in
season one.
So Watson we also have to talk about that
WTF affair that he had during the episode.
I will understand if you think it was complete
garbage, but I feel like they did that for
him just to make him feel like he did have
the moral high ground like to complicate his
character so that he had his own secrets.
He was keeping from everyone else just like
Mary had her secrets in Sherlock has his own
secrets.
So the only other like real big thing to remember
for next week's episode is the sticky note
on Mycroft's fridge 13th he call someone we
don't know who it is but it seems rather ominous
like he setting something in motion.
So that'll probably carry forward in the next
week's episode, so he didn't know episode
two is going to air next week episode three
the week after that.
So will be like one episode each Sunday after
this so if you spotted any in the episode
that I didn't mention just write them below
in the comments.
But what can happen is is episode two will
air next week then episode three will air
the week after that.
So I will do a giveaway each week and then
tomorrow was can happen is is all due like
a 2017 video for like all the big stuff that
I'm in be doing videos for the next month
or to the exciting stuff is coming up that
you guys should be really hype about, so it
can be awesome start of 2017 right yeah Sherlock
is back while you guys wait for that to post
you can click here for like my big Sherlock
playlist and you can click here to learn all
about the new DC comics TV show that's coming
this year that you so much watching everybody
thought five I'll see you guys tonight!